tt you know up in 1507 an alchemist
strapped chicken feathers to his butt
and tried to fly from Scotland to France
did you also know that the Victorians
used to race tea leaves how does one
race a tea leaf you may ask and which
tea leaf one well these are all
questions that I answer in sticker flag
in it a thousand years of bizarre
history from Britain and beyond for
those of you who are thinking who the
hell is this strange Englishman and what
does he want well as many of you may
already know I'm Erin I created on host
the educational YouTube channel 42 but
today I come to you with something other
than a video words in fact I've written
a whole book of them and maybe a few
pictures that's right I am very very
excited to launch my new book that I've
been working on for a year and I've been
researching my entire life this isn't
just rehashed content for my youtube
channel this is a personal passion
project of around 100,000 words of
fascinating content that I've never
brought to you before and I suspect many
of you may have never read about such as
the true story of a band of unruly
eighteenth-century Yorkshire men who
almost crushed the English Treasury from
a pub yes that really happened and all
its brilliant guts and intriguing detail
can be read about in this unique book
you see I make videos on a lot of topics
but more than all else I love history I
want to show you how our wondrous weird
and often wacky past is more intriguing
more bloody and contain significantly
more incest than Game of Thrones I want
to tell you how our history is so
bizarre you really couldn't make it up
stick a flag in it is packed full of all
the interesting history you were never
taught at school probably because it was
too naughty or too exciting he will read
chapters such as Adam the leper has
leprosy a priest hides in a wall forgets
to bring a packed lunch
and starves to death Henry the six
becomes England's shittest King Francis
Drake sails around the world and makes
it home in time to defeat the Spanish
Armada a Scotsman gets lost in Africa
and a Welshman otters something quite
memorable and basically everyone gets
the black death and dies this book is
unapologetically crude and witty laced
with intrigue deception and the noir 'fl
lot of death this is history
like you've never known it before but I
need your help to get it published
I'm crowdfunding this book with the
amazing unbound who published unique
fresh and genuinely interesting books
that are about more than just horny
teenage vampires if you pledge to
support this book not only are you
helping to make it a possibility but
you'll of course also get an early
access first edition hardback copy as
soon as it's printed and if you want to
pledge slightly more you can get a
signed copy a limited edition poster of
the five shittest kings of all time and
you can get a limited edition mug
featuring the hilarious flying alchemist
who you can read all about in the book
but yes an alchemist did try to fly you
can also have a personal time capture or
buried an unbound HQ in your name and in
honor of the flying alchemist i will
strap feathers and a balloon with your
name on it to a copy of the book and see
how far it can fly there's overdue two
awards so go ahead and take a look most
importantly every single one of you
lovely people who helps to make this
book a reality will have their name
printed in the book for all eternity
there are also exciting stretch goals
that together we can unlock if you get
all your mates on your grandma to pledge
also once the project reaches 100% the
book will definitely be published but if
it reaches one hundred and twenty five
percent then every supporter will get a
digital ebook version to download along
with their hardback copy if it reaches
one hundred and fifty percent then every
support will receive a downloadable PDF
that i've written have the best
beheadings of all
time and if it reaches 175 percent every
supporter will get a special bookmark
with a design unique to this book and
some nifty pin badges so you can
puncture a hole in your favorite shirt
and if the project reaches 200% then a
bonus chapter will be unlocked and added
to the book all about how Britain built
America and subsequently how America
gained its freedom from its Imperial
European yoke but wait Erin your book
may be total crap I hear you well if you
head on over to one bound right now the
links in the description you can read
two full chapters of the book for free I
desperately want to share all these
amazing stories with you that I've
written about that will have you winning
pub quizzes and annoying your colleagues
with true tales of amazing adventures
and very smelly peasants but only with
your support can that's happen so if you
desperately can't wait to read this book
or you just want a very pretty signed
copy for your bookshelf then please head
on over to unban right now and together
let's make this book a reality thank you